okay I want to walk us through a bit of
an exercise to understand what happens
when people become resistant to an
antibiotic what are the molecular basis
for resistance
it's nothing magical it's really things
that you can understand based on what
you've learned during various parts of
the course but I just want to remind you
about this sort of dreadful a schematic
here which shows how rapidly resistance
emerges two different antibiotics by
showing you the year that the drugs are
introduced and the year that resistance
is development one of the newest
antibiotics biotics to be introduced
people thought they're always different
mechanism of action it should be pretty
resilient it should last for a while it
should be useful with daptomycin it's a
cyclic peptide antibiotic which has a
particular structure that doesn't look
like a lot of the others and honestly it
was two to three years before resistance
emerged so what I want to do is think
together about what what are the ways in
which a bacterium could evolve to
develop resistance against an antibiotic
so here we've got the target
we know that the antibiotic is very
effective against the target what types
of things could happen in the bacterium
to make it manage to just ignore the
antibiotic and resist the antibiotic any
suggestions so it's very simple there's
a molecular target could be topos
isomerize it could be it could be the
impact the ribosome and the machinery
for synthesizing proteins it could be
the machinery the cross links
peptidoglycan what sorts of approaches
what sorts of strategies might evolve to
make that antibiotic stop working okay
fire yes
okay right so antibiotic gets in the
enzyme breaks up the antibiotics so
evolution to destroy the antibiotic and
that's very much what happens with
penicillin the key aspect of the
structure that so useful suddenly
becomes invalidated through a
degradation of the beta lactam bond so
that's one of them what's next yeah ah
[Music]
so maybe there could be uptake decreased
so that's quite hard but there could be
some evolution of the cell wall to make
it less permeable to the antibiotic
because we're usually relying on
antibiotics to diffuse impassively
so if the membrane this could be them in
a membrane of a gram-negative bacterium
or the outer membrane of a gram-negative
bacterium that has a slightly different
composition could physically change its
structure these are tough things to
evolve all at once but it's certainly a
possibility we talked about update what
about what else could happen yes okay so
this guy could just we've got a circular
antibiotic usually but this just changes
the target just changes it can't bind
anymore through mutation so that the
antibiotic simply doesn't bind it gets
in but it's changed and that happens a
lot it also happens a lot one can think
of antibiotic resistance very much along
the same veins as one thinks of
to chemo therapeutic agents you're
targeting a kinase your drug works great
a year later the cancer comes back
because there's a single mutation in
your target this happens a lot with the
the EGF kinase wrasses and so on there's
a dramatic change so this change would
be changing the target you mentioned two
things right
I thought maybe not on the surface okay
so there could be some kind of import
strategy so some antibiotics just
diffuse some go in through targeted
import and that might change so that the
antibiotic can't get in anymore
other thoughts so there's a couple of
other sneaky ways I mean you've got to
sort of give these bacteria credit for
maximum sneakiness so if influx is an
issue what about a phlox the biggest
problem with antibiotics against gram
negatives is that they weigh up regulate
a flux pumps they just like cover their
cells with pumps that just go you're
gonna give me an antibiotic I'm just
gonna lob it straight back out to you so
the e flux pumps increase so then
they're molecules we have a lot of
reflux pumps to just check out things
that are not that we don't want in our
cells the bacteria have similar things
they will they're fairly promiscuous
exporting pumps that will bind to things
that don't look like things that should
be in a cell and literally bind to them
on the inside of the membrane send them
back to the outside of the membrane so
gram-negative bacteria can massively opt
regulate the production of a pump that
they already have but they just make
much more of them so in many cases you
can hardly test a new compound because
it's getting pumped out as fast as it
gets pumped
what could be a strategy when this
happens because people are doing this
you inhibit the pump so you make your
antibiotic it what it works great but
you stop the pump working so you have to
give to drugs the drug that's the
antibiotic to the target and the drug
that inhibits the pump and that happens
similarly with this mechanism where the
antibiotic gets destroyed you can
recover from this by inhibiting the
destroying enzyme and then your
antibiotic doesn't get destroyed when it
gets into the cells so there's one
extremely important formulation of
antibiotic that is used
it's called augmentin and what it is is
a penicillin plus a beta lactamase
inhibitor it's the drug that works plus
a drug that inhibits the enzyme that
destroys the drug people get this all
the time every day of the week this
stuff is prescribed it's a two compound
cocktail that has something to overcome
the resistance so that your drug still
works in a cell all right and there's
one more key mechanism and what bacteria
will just do is they say well you know
I'm getting dosed with this much
antibiotic what's a good way around it
is to massively up regulate the
biosynthesis of the target to a state
where you just can't saturate at all so
up regulation of the target is a very
very common thing so you you should have
just increased the number of transcripts
being made you increase the amount of
target being made so that even if
antibiotics are flooding into cells
there's just not enough to inhibit all
of the target because it's been up
regulated by ten or a hundredfold so
what I think is cool about all these
mechanisms they all make sense you just
kind of had to think of them
do I stop the drug getting in do I stop
it getting pumped out do I stop it
getting degraded do I make more target
all of those things are very viable and
they are strategies that are used quite
commonly so very commonly both in
bacteria and in viruses we seldom give
one compound we commonly give multiple
compounds to sort of hit multiple
targets because if you gave a two drug
cocktail to a bacterium but you knew
there was going to be up regulation of a
target you could hope that the other
enzyme is still a target so you give
cocktails of Enza of drugs as opposed to
single drugs and you're gonna see that
very relevantly
when we talk about the HIV virus because
it's only been that HIV has become HIV
AIDS has become a treatable condition
because of drug cocktails not because of
singular drugs that inhibit one step and
you'll see it very very commonly there
any questions about this stuff okay so
we're gonna move on to viruses
and so I will actually update the slides
that are on the web to give you this
sort of set of information so you can
see it in one place
okay viruses
viruses are fascinating organisms they
they don't have the right to be alive
because they don't have the machinery to
be alive but they exploit the hosts
mechanisms for completing their
viability so viruses more or less I
think we like to think of them as living
a borrowed life and they only survive if
they have spent some time inside a host
cell so we will see with viruses some
viruses specifically target humans other
viruses may spend some time in different
organisms and then target humans and be
carried around amongst different
organisms but the key thing is that
viruses can only actually replicate once
they're inside a host cell because they
basically exploit all of the host cells
machinery to do that so viruses don't
make many of their own enzymes they
don't have their own amino acid supplies
or all the metabolic enzymes that are
required for life all the replication
transcription translation machinery they
just borrow the host machinery but
they're in Li individual components that
the virus will bring along with it to to
cover certain things that are not
provided by the hosts but viral genomes
are tiny they may comprise maybe eight
genes some of them are bigger but they
are very very small genomes they're very
what we call parsimonious genomes so
there's overlapping genes so you can
keep the genome tiny by having
compacting
the size of the genome and then there
are bigger viruses some of the biggest
viruses approached the sizes of bacteria
like the mini viruses and they may have
been an intermediate step from virus to
more elaborated organisms and those
viruses have a bit more machinery within
their context people obviously there's
no fossil record for viruses it's not
like we can go sort of you know go
exploring and find a fossil record but
where these viruses are being found is
in the permafrost so they're frozen
they've been frozen there for centuries
so people are finding really sort of
scary things in the Siberian permafrost
because the viruses are preserved there
and some of these giant viruses are
being discovered in in those locations
and if that's not the subjects a
wonderful sci-fi book site I don't know
what is because there are and I tend to
read those things because my favorite
thing is finding mistakes in them so
there's there's a lot out there about
those kinds of things so let me just
show you a tiny bit about you know this
is that boring old learned genetics
thing right from the beginning but I
want to take you back to his sizes so we
know all this stuff we've we've learnt
it to death hemoglobin antibodies the
ribosome but what I really want to point
out on this slide
is that the smallest viruses like the
Rhino virus that's the common cold or
the hepatitis virus and not barely any
bigger than a ribosome okay so obviously
there's not much in the virus but all
the components of the virus have evolved
to enable them to sneakily
get into host cells exploit the host
cell machinery and then replicate inside
her cell and then get out of the host
cell are ready to invest it in fact
another host cell so I want you to
really notice these sizes so the Rhino
virus is similar to a ribosome but some
viruses which we will talk about the
influenza virus and the
HIV virus are a little bigger but none
of them compete up to the size of a
bacterium and just to get you into that
mode very there are the bacteria and
there's the mitochondrion remember and a
symbiont theory bacteria similar size to
mitochondria and much much bigger than
any typical virus but giant viruses
approach some of these bigger sizes
they're a different ball game altogether
and we won't talk about them apart from
the fact that they're really cool and
they're in the permafrost okay all right
so another impressive thing about
viruses because they look some of them
like this phage a bacterial virus they
look like things lunar landers for
example or sort of other kinds of things
some of them a linear some of them sort
of different kinds of shapes a lot of
viruses icosahedra we'll talk about that
in a moment so the the but the fact
sheet about viruses is first of all
sizes and the typical viral size if
there is something typical expand from
20 to 400 nanometers in diameter so
remember the ribosome sits right at this
end with respect to size but bacteria
can't come to a yellow lecture here
remember a 1 to 10 micrometers in length
depending on what dimension you're
measuring so considerably smaller
nanometer scale micrometer scale for
bacteria so that's the first thing that
it's important to know they're very
small the next critical thing is what's
in a virus what is it what's the blood
and guts of a virus and it's either DNA
or RNA and it can be single-stranded or
double stranded so it has its genetic
material its genetic material is usually
dedicated to making more copies of
itself so if the virus has a coat a coat
of proteins the virus has to have a gene
for that because the host isn't going to
have a coat for a virus so the virus has
to have certain specialized things that
complete itself that can't be borrowed
from the host cell so and they can be
let's see they can be what are called
capsid viruses or enveloped capsid
viruses just have a protein coat the
enveloped viruses have a membrane
surrounding them with proteins stuck
into them so the enveloped viruses have
an outer membrane which is studded with
proteins but what is cool about the
virus is it never makes its own
membranes it doesn't make its
phospholipids it just as it emerges from
a host cell pinches a piece of the cell
surface it steals the cellular membrane
with it as its emerging from a cell and
you'll see this in a video how cool that
is
all the proteins that all the components
of the virus cluster near the surface of
a membrane and then you have this
wonderful endocytosis using the host
membranes so the virus never has to make
its its own membranes and not all
viruses are enveloped just some of them
and you'll see examples of each
so the definition really is that they're
small infectious agents that they only
replicate inside living cells because
they have to exploit a lot of the
machinery of living and of living cells
and they can infect humans other animals
there are plant viruses bacteria have by
so all living organisms have biros --is
that infect them and but viruses are
usually targeted very specifically to
the cells that they infect and in fact
you will see with HIV it's not just a
virus that it infects a human host it
infects specifically and that was why it
was so so terrifying this action t-cells
that's the one cell type in the host
that it goes after so virus is very
often target to particular organs we're
within their hosts and that's why we
know some of the viruses and you'll see
that the names of the viruses are
related to their organs that they may
infect okay so I wanna just briefly
describe the terms we talked about these
with all infectious diseases that they
may be endemic epidemic and pandemic
endemic is the term that we use for
there's a very low level of an
infectious agent in the population it's
completely out of control within control
there's a few cases but there's not
transfer from person to person or animal
to animal we would call that endemic a
very very low level of virus that
doesn't cause any threat as soon as the
virus or bacterial infections agents
starts spreading amongst a local
population we would call that a local
epidemic so all of a community all of a
country so very much defined
geographically into a particular space
where there's transmission of viruses
from person to person or animal to
person within a community there has to
be direct contact but now with travel
the many viruses reach pandemic stages
which means worldwide so plane travel
really caused enormous trouble because
you can have a virus in you know in
Africa or Asia somebody gets on a plane
and ends up
somewhere else and the virus has been
moved to a new country I made the
terrible mistake of reading hot zone on
a plane one time which is about Marburg
virus which is where people just sort of
basically just stop bleeding out in the
spot and I'm reading this book and it's
describing the steps of someone who had
Marburg and was just sort of bleeding
out next to them are you crazy reading
this book on a plane because they were
describing how Marburg was just moved
from its country of origin to you know
to New York City or something like that
so you remember when we had the Ebola
concerns there was a real genuine worry
that Ebola would jump through flight
travel through people coming in at
airports and end up with a pandemic of
Ebola when there was a real problem with
the avian flu in Asia Singapore that's
very very protective of its territory
had senses that would you would go into
Singapore you go down this two huge
escalators and they had sensors
measuring people's temperature at a
distance as they came down the escalator
and hauling people over and you know
sort of interrogating them where have
you been to see whether they would be
allowed to enter Singapore because the
flight travel people getting on planes
spreading a very contagious virus to a
new country is very very realistic the
issue with spreading - pandemic
situations is very very important when
one thinks of history because when the
Europeans try to work on curring the
Americas in particular South America and
Central America they brought with them a
lot of viruses but there was an innate
sort of resistance to because of years
and years of exposure but these
communities have never seen these
viruses so millions of people died
because they were suddenly exposed to a
human virus that they'd never seen
before through transmission from a
country
where there wasn't such a problem with
the virus so the indigenous peoples of
the Americas Australia and New Zealand
had terrible consequences there some of
you have probably heard of the Spanish
flu and that was towards the tail end of
World War one and his thought to have
killed as many as a hundred million
people and that in fact is quite
interesting it's called the Spanish flu
but there's some evidence that it might
have originated in the Americas in the
boats that took troops over to Europe to
help at the tail end of the First World
War and there's a really interesting
book about that whole story that the
Spanish flu may not have originated in
Spain and it's a it's definitely a
worthwhile read so that tells you a lot
about the statistics of viruses I just
want to highlight here we talk about HIV
is a very serious virus it emerged in
the in the early 80s so there's this
current well in the 2011 there were 35
million people infected there's about
two and a half million new cases a year
but what's fascinating about HIV there
was a stage before the really good
antivirals were available that if the
mother had HIV the baby would get HIV
but now if there's treatment of the
mother and the baby is is delivered
often by a caesarean section the baby
can escape being infected with the virus
due to the new antivirals so that's
really important that the originally
there were a lot of cases of newborns
who simply got HIV during birth but now
that can be there's escape from that
which is really really cool the viral
load can be brought really low with the
common antivirals
against HIV and that next generation
isn't doesn't have that sentence okay so
I mentioned to you that a lot of viruses
are basically named after the organs
that they hit so I've just got a human
being here with a lot of different
viruses that hit different place
and I just want to point out a few
points viruses may be targets nowadays
of childhood vaccinations and many of
you I hope all of you have had
vaccinations too many of these common
viruses there is a concern now through
these other with communities that are
deciding not to vaccinate children
that's a huge social problem that may
initially sort of people can get away
with it because there's community
vaccination you're sort of you're in a
community where a lot of people have a
resistance or some sort of immunity
through a virus but as communities
become less and less vaccinated then
later generations will start to get the
disease seriously and that's actually
happening parts of the world where
there's there used to be no polio and
now there's polio emerging because the
community immunity has been is fading
away so we hope that people get
vaccinated that's for sure the
vaccinations work several vaccinations
several viruses were pretty much
eradicated smallpox and polio were two
of the the real booster examples of
childhood vaccinations that worked and
worked amazingly well but now there's a
problem with failure to vaccinate in
certain parts of the world so that's a
concern and then another interesting
thing is that some viruses whoops let's
go back sorry I don't know it's all a
secret you can't see that just yet okay
some viruses lead to cancer so human
papilloma virus where there is a vaccine
that people who have HIV some of the
types of efforts hepatitis and
epstein-barr are all associated with
later cases of cancer so that's
important to know so often cancers are
named by their organ that they attach so
even though the three the five
hepatitises all attacks the liver they
not related there just five viruses that
go after the liver so if you've had a
vaccination against happy it doesn't
protect you from Hep B or C by a
relationship they're very very different
so you have to have different
vaccinations so this just gives you a
nice view of human viruses what their
names are what organs they may attack
what sorts of things they might be
associated with but the trouble is this
nomenclature doesn't get you anywhere
towards understanding the mechanism of a
virus so what we will focus on is a much
better system for describing viruses
that's based on whether they have DNA or
RNA within the genomes that they import
into her cells and whether that DNA or
RNA is single-stranded or
double-stranded because that truly tells
us a lot more about the virus and maybe
the steps that could be inhibited to
prevent the viral infections but first
of all just a few pictures here some so
viruses can be rod-shaped they can look
like they can be icosahedra they can
just have a capsid so I mentioned they
may just have a protein coat that sets
of idea of repeating proteins that pack
into a beautiful structure very commonly
an icosahedron and I'll show you why
that is or they may be enveloped viruses
like influenza has a membrane a surface
around where the DNA is packaged all of
these have nucleic acids packaged within
them DNA or RNA single or double
stranded and in the case of the
enveloped viruses that membrane it's a
normal membrane it's just like your
membrane in fact it is your membrane
will have proteins dotted within it
that's actually serve as recognition to
the host cells they'll grab onto her
cells and be the source of the infection
into the host cells this is a bacterial
virus unless I said I just love the way
they I mean they really look like this
this you know the cartoon is really the
cartoon of what the
looks like unless sort of pretty amazing
and they kind of should they keep their
nucleic acid in the head here they land
on their sort of feet and they shoot of
the nucleic acid material into the host
cells so that's a very interesting of
course they're singers okay so why are
many viruses that are capsid viruses
icosahedra so it ends up being a problem
of geometry so how can you make a
perfect coat around something with very
very few building blocks of different
types like if every building block in
that coat was different the virus would
have to have genes for all of them what
viruses can do is they can have genes
for like three pieces of a module of the
virus so I'm going to show you how these
capsid viruses get assembled so here
color coded is an icosahedral virus
where I've coded in red yellow green and
blue a triangular component this is
really cool that is a single sort of
panel on that icosahedral virus that
comes together as a triangle through non
covalent interactions between three
proteins okay you see that panel there
what you can then do is see how that
panel would fit into a pentagon with an
extra triangle stuck onto it and you can
fit that triangle into the Pentagon and
also into the additional piece then you
can start to visualize how you could
build an icosahedron
from those pieces because they represent
each of those phases within the virus so
you can go from this which is a set of
building blocks okay that I just showed
you then you can assemble them like this
and one of these would be this part of
the icosahedron and then you just have a
bunch of copies of it and you can see
how you would assemble that and years
ago I decided to decorate my Christmas
free but icosahedra so I went through
this geometrical thing and believe me it
works really nicely you can put together
an icosahedron and build an icosahedron
you can spring in gold and put it on
your Christmas tree it's kind of
fanatical but it really it's highly
recommended ok all right so let's now
get down to something a little bit more
serious than Christmas trees and things
all right so I told you that the
classification of viruses by what organ
they attack or who discovered them or
anything is it's just is a vagary that's
not so useful to the non physicians
because you can't immediately know oh
this is how the virus gets into the host
cell this is how the virus uses its
genetic material to make new viruses so
what was developed by Baltimore David
Baltimore used to be um it was kind of
interesting David Baltimore very famous
person and Nobel laureate used to be at
MIT when I was at Caltech and we moved
in opposite directions I'm not sure it
was a great trade for MIT but it was a
great trade for Caltech so I ended up
with David Baltimore's labs in building
68 because we did that swap in 1999 or
something like that so I thought that
was pretty interesting anyway so what
Baltimore decided is was much better to
classify viruses by the type of genetic
material like are they DNA or RNA is
that DNA or RNA single-stranded or
double-stranded because depending on
what the genetic material in the virus
is once that gets unloaded into a host
cell certain steps have to happen in
order for the virus to be able to
replicate that genetic material to
convert it ultimately into the proteins
it needs and then to package up a new by
new viral genetic material into viral
capsids so that they can then be sprung
out of the cell and go infect another
sounds so the classification basically
went this way
think of it what the major goal in the
impacted cell is to get the virus to a
stage where the virus has plus messenger
RNA it has RNA that can be read by the
hosts ribosomes and converted into
proteins so the overall goal of the
virus if we give it sort of some you
know conscience shall we say is to make
its viral material into messenger RNA
now the virus doesn't include messenger
RNA that's just what is made transiently
but the virus may have single-stranded
DNA
it may have plus sense RNA it may have
negative sense RNA it could have
double-stranded DNA or it could even
have double-stranded RNA and depending
on what that genetic material is what
the Baltimore classification of a virus
would be so depending on what's inside
the virus then they can be classified
and what we're gonna go through today
and and on Friday is examples of class 1
class 5 and class 6 viruses so we can
see how that genetic material ultimately
becomes a new viral organ is very thin a
host cell or at least the components
thereof ready to be sprung out of a
virus and there's one important point
that I want to also address whoops
body lytic all right there are two ways
in which viruses escape their host cell
they may be budding so here you have a
host cell the viral components all
congregate near the surface of the
membrane from the inside and then the
host cell buds off the viral components
go with it and the bud splits off so the
host cell has its nucleus is still
intact
HIV is such a virus shoot HIV
and kill its hosts that's the best sign
of a parasite and wants the host to
stick around so it just buds off the
other types of viruses oolitic and
basically the cell just busts open and
throws out the virus so they're in two
categories some of them are budding the
enveloped viruses have to be budding
because they're gonna take with them the
membrane of the host cell all right
so that's another important difference
okay so what we got here so ultimately
the goal is to be able to make a plus
strand mRNA for protein synthesis so we
really need to have the appropriate
sense of the RNA that will dictate
protein synthesis so let's first of all
look at one of the simple versions a
double-stranded DNA virus and this is
represented by the smallpox virus so
everybody's heard of that and herpes
simplex and these are both enveloped
viruses so that means they have a
membrane shell and so I'm just gonna
walk you through the steps of going from
the double-stranded DNA to make a new
virus so here's the virus it has a
capsid as well as a membrane envelope
and there's recognition between the
virus and the host cell
we'll talk very specifically about what
that recognition is when we talk about
HIV because that's very well categorized
once the virus gets into the host cell
is sort of spilled off all the coat and
dumps out it's double-stranded DNA the
viral DNA into the host cell and then
that DNA can in the nucleus can
replicate in two more copies of the
viral DNA or it can be transcribed into
messenger RNA which is then the code for
all those capsid proteins that the virus
needs and then these start to self
assemble within the host cell where the
capsid proteins wrap around the buyer
around the viral genetic material they
accumulate near the surface of the cell
and then they bud off from the cells so
that's how you go from simple DNA so
these these processes are completely
based on the human enzymes that do those
processes replication we got to
replicate DNA we're going to have to do
that in the nucleus transcription we're
gonna have to ship out part of the DNA
from the nucleus to the cytoplasm and
make we're gonna have to make a copy of
the messenger RNA and ship it out of the
nucleus and then we're gonna use the
host right ribosomes the hosts amino
acids the building blocks and everything
to make a new protein that is not our
host cell protein it's the capsid
protein obviously the human cell isn't
going to be making a capsid protein so
that's the main thing that the virus had
to encode right it had to have the DNA
to make that so that all looks sort of
fairly simple and the steps make sense
this is why we covered this virus first
because it really you know it's kind of
the most transparent to understand so
this transient stage of sort of
borrowing machinery and as I mentioned
here the virus can spring out of the
host cell yes they start to just be too
much of a burden to the body so they're
just you know if they're in side cells
and exploiting the resources of the cell
they're basically there harming it but
they're not destroying it instantly
every lifecycle they're just using
resources to replicate and then go get
spread to another cell and another cell
where they'll keep using resources so
it's really just an overload of the
system it's a very good point but they
can stick around a long time and with
HIV you're gonna see what really sneaky
thing they do is because they put their
genome into the host genome and that's
sort of really pretty terrifying
I always ask this question but it's kind
of a silly
you know what is life viruses alive well
they're kind of alive but they're not
really alive unless they have someplace
to live but oh we all like that so
that's very philosophical so we'll move
right on here okay so when you think of
a virus this is the original central
dogma all the moving parts of the
central dogma and note so that when you
think of a virus what double what does
double-stranded DNA
need from the host it's got all of these
things it's got the polymer the host has
the polymerase it has the DNA dependent
RNA polymerase it's got all the
ribosomal machinery so the only thing
that the virus needs is the gene for its
capsid proteins so you can peel out from
that entire lifecycle the one unique
thing about the virus so that's a
double-stranded DNA okay let's now move
to a different type of Y which is a
negative stranded RNA virus and these
are quite important because these form
the basis for let me just go to the
diseases this is the influenza virus and
I'm going to mention it's very important
points relative to influenza viruses so
influenza virus is what's known as a
segmented virus and what that means is
is that it's genome in this case it's
negative stranded RNA is in pieces
a lot a lot of other viruses just have a
single strand of genome single nucleic
acid strand so it's just one piece where
portions of that nucleic acid code for
different proteins and they'll often
code for initially poly proteins that
get broken up and we'll see a virus with
a single strand when we look at HIV but
the influenza virus has a segmented
genome and that's very relevant for its
lifestyle because we'll see in a moment
how influenza virus can can cause more
damage than we anticipate because of
recombination of different copies of the
segmented virus through differences but
let's first of all take a look at the
life cycle of this virus and then we'll
move on to dealing with the issue of the
segmentation okay so here's a typical
enveloped virus with a capsid inside
there's the negative stranded RNA that
gets into the host cell and you make a
new hat you dump into the host cell
the viral genomic RNA that can get
copied the minus strand RNA gets copied
to the plus strand RNA which becomes the
messenger for protein synthesis in the
cell so you've gone in with minus strand
you've made the plus strand which is the
messenger and that encodes all the
proteins that are needed for a new virus
okay and some of those proteins may have
signal sequences they may be shipped to
the surface of the cell and they may be
planted in the outside cellular membrane
of the host cells and what you see here
is copies of those proteins actually in
the surface of a cell so what happens
with this virus is once all the moving
parts are made
they congregate at the surface of a cell
get packaged and then bud off from the
cell so remember all the rules you
learned about where proteins end up in
the cell are all good still here because
the capsid proteins have to get to a
cell membrane so they're translated with
a signal sequence they congregate I
don't know how this self-assembly occurs
but it's a fascinating process so that
ultimately you bud off an intact variant
from the host cell but the key thing
that the virus has to have is something
that will copy negative stranded RNA to
plus stranded RNA which is going to be
the messenger so the virus also has to
code for a particular protein that's
unique to its lifestyle so it has an RA
dependent RNA polymerase we don't use an
RNA dependent RNA polymerase but the
virus needs it to take its negative
strand RNA to a plus strand RNA which
will be the messenger so does that make
sense so obviously that's a moving part
that it needs to provide to the host now
what's this about segmented viruses
that's quite important so oh and I just
want to underscore here what defines the
destination of these proteins whether
they're capsid proteins or proteins are
going to be packaged within the virus is
basically just the same rules that apply
that we talked about when we talked
about protein trafficking okay so every
year has a whole panic did you get your
flu shot is it gonna work this year oh
my god millions of people are gonna get
sick go get your flu shot it's
tetravalent it's trivalent and so on so
what we're trying to do every year is
predict what the virus is gonna look
like so we have to put there teams of
people who sometimes get it wrong who
predict the variation in these genes and
they look at winter in the southern
hemisphere because that precedes us and
try to guess what's gonna happen in
winter in the northern hemisphere
and we get to try and put together you
know a vaccination package but the
problem with the viral influenza virus
is that there can be not just dressed
like mutations small mutations happening
a little bit of a time but there can be
recombination of the genes because they
are segmented into totally new virus
particles that have different properties
so viruses don't just drift in their
genomic sequence they can have dramatic
shifts in their sequences that occur
what's through combinations of viruses
that come that have infected different
animals so some of the common strains
when we talk about certain strains that
have been very very troublesome to
humans may result from such a
combination so this would be the
Eurasian Pig flu the classic Pig flu the
human flu the bird flu is in certain
communities where people often live with
their livestock a cell gets infected
with viruses a human virus the swine
virus they can mix and match together
and you can make a totally different
viral composition where you've got one
protein one piece of genetic information
from the swine flu and seven more from
the human flu and what that can suddenly
mean is that first of all the bite the
vaccines don't work at all but they may
have very very different properties for
infectivity the protein that is
expressed that may cause that very first
attack of the virus on yourselves in the
upper lungs may be very different to the
types of the protein that comes from the
swine flu may give you much more serious
lung infections because they can go
deeper into the lungs so it can be very
small changes but pulling an enzyme a
piece of gene from a completely
different organism and matching it up
with the rest of the genes from the
human virus that makes for dramatic
shifts in viral infections that
that cause these sorts of sudden
tectonic shifts where we've really got a
deal with a virus there are two terms up
here there's H and n these are
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase there
are two proteins that are in the viral
coat so you'll often hear viruses
referred to as h1n1 h3 n3 and it's just
the variant of those proteins that are
in the viruses see these little terms
here that's what that means
what type of hemagglutinin what type of
neuraminidase is on the surface of the
virus so I am done for today a next
class will be exclusively about the AIDS
HIV virus where we'll go into that life
cycle and also talk about resistance
therapeutic agents and combination
therapies
you